mi nombre es jaime también soy escritora
el año pasado publiqué un libro con una
editorial española
y me gustaría explicarles mi historia de
una manera didáctica madura y seria
quería hacerles una pregunta al 112 de
esa vista para montana
y bueno les voy a explicar a los que no
han visto de una manera rápida hannah
montana es historia bueno la serie de
una chica común y corriente que cuando
se pone la peluca rubia se vuelve una
cantante famosa millonaria con talento
entonces por qué les digo esto porque yo
soy santana
pero yo les voy a explicar por qué para
montarla tiene dos vidas están en las
montañas están miley cyrus está bueno mi
suerte entonces 'hannah montana' tienen
la vida es famosa porque yo vendría a
ser el score que es mi alter ego
escritor soy escritora soy un poco
conocida en el mundo imaginario y
después tengo también amigas famosas y
cosas así y después está del lado del
mail y stuart que vendrás eliminar eso
yo también
que es hoy el esa de la carrera de
turismo hago mis prácticas duermo mucho
entonces
si les explico de otra manera tengo lo
mejor de dos mundos entonces
ahora te voy a explicar un poco no yo
vengo de dos familias muy talentosas y
les cuento escriben poesía recita cantan
bailan tocan 80 instrumentos toma fotos
cocina un montón de cosas entonces
obviamente mis padres no son no son
excluidos de estos mis padres
[Música]
desde muy pequeña mi mamá me inculcó
mucho la lectura aparte de todos los
talentos que tenemos me encontré mucho a
la lectura y también el encontrar otros
cuentos entonces también estaba en papá
mi mamá no es tanto de leer pero si le
encanta hablar entonces me contaban
muchas historias que él inventaba
segundo para este ser más creativo que
vamos a conocer él nos tenía siempre
juegos mentales esas personas que que
tienen un amor tan rápido que tú les
cuentas un chiste y te lo devuelve
entonces desde muy pequeña siempre me
fomentó lo que era la creatividad
entonces si les cuento más o menos
cuando entro de primaria como los seis o
siete años puede detectar algo llamado
tdh que es el déficit de atención y
concentración entonces eso también me
trajo muchos problemas pues me distraía
me no me concentraba también me llama
mucho la atención bajaba las notas y no
podían este incluirme tanto en el salón
no con mis compañeros
entonces también por eso sufrí el
bullying pero yo no sabía que estaba
subiendo porque porque en ese momento no
había tanta información estoy hablando
de hacer no sé pues 78 años 9 que no
había es el internet a la mano como lo
tienen ustedes ahora entonces no están
todas las herramientas que tenemos ahora
no sé pues si pasa algo por internet
este denunciamos lo que está pasando y
también automáticamente se vuelve viral
y se resuelve
entonces yo en ese momento no no tenía
esas herramientas no lo dije menos mal
que no lo pasé tan mal pero
lo que sí es que estuve en alrededor de
6 colegios y en el último del séptimo
donde terminó en los tres últimos años
de secundaria
me sentí que logré incluirse en el salón
me acuerdo que incluso llega a mi casa y
le decía mami los chicos me caen bien o
sea me hacen reír y todo sea verdad
en ese momento recién sentí que estaba
siendo parte de un salón
y entonces también gracias a esto
él
gracias a mi prima conocí el punto del
funk fix y qué es eso yo fan de los
jonas brothers encontré un mundo donde
podías leer en internet gratis
y que en una historia pasada famoso
escrito con un fans entonces yo tenía el
mundo a mi disposición entonces de tanto
leer también obviamente retomen la
lectura que era algo que había tenido
abandonado más o menos al 15 años por
curiosidad empecé a escribir porque
decía si ellos pueden hacerlo por mí o
no
en el momento de ponerme a escribir
también me acuerdo incluso del colegio
ya los 22 últimos colegios leían las
historias que quería después también me
volviste más tecnológica y escribir en
el teléfono y me quitan el teléfono para
poderles entonces ella pero mis primeras
lecturas después también gracias a mi
prima en contra estos foros de internet
donde escribían y yo también empecé a
escribir a y gracias a este foro fui
encontrando muchos más foros y otras
páginas y hay una página de una
plataforma naranja que es una de mis más
conocidas en cuanto a leer gratis por
internet
gracias a esta página que yo sé que
tiene comentarios malos y buenos pero
para mí un logro porque porque ahí
termina mi primera historia y de hecho
es la historia que publiqué en físico
entonces pero hay un problema que pasó
lo que pasa es que yo en ese momento
había subido la historia y tenía algo de
cinco mil visitas más o menos
me río porque me acuerdo de esto ahora
me río pero en este momento no porque lo
que pasa es que reúne a todos mis
hermanos ya mí y nos dicen saben que
chicos yo sé que nosotros tenemos
problemas fuertes económicos pero aquí
hay algo que quiero agradecerles porque
nosotros a pesar de todo estamos unidos
y nos tenemos confianza si no nos
ocultamos nada para esto mis papás no
sabían que yo escribía entonces se dan
cuenta y mamá me arroz al cachetazo sin
saber que me estaba que me está dando
una lección pero es que si se ama más
entonces
me sentí culpable y no sé por qué pero
un arranque de locura borre todo y
después más tranquila su hijo de mamá le
dice es a destiempo a mí yo escribo y un
borrar una historia de cinco mil visitas
porque tú hiciste que nos teníamos
confianza y no les estaba teniendo
confianza entonces obviamente si se
imagina desliza la mano no no me pegó no
pero si me gritó me gritó bonito pero me
gritó y me dijo cómo se te ocurre borrar
en la historia es dos mil visitas y es
algo que me gusta hacer o sea nosotros
te vamos a apoyar siempre con algo que
te guste entonces más adelante también
sólo con de un rail y obviamente también
me apoyaron entonces con el apoyo de
papás incluso me acuerdo que estabas
intención y eso bueno es que se lo dejo
dios
y este es el mismo año de la historia
llegó su primero millón de visitas
entonces bueno con esto les quiero
contar qué
yo sé que de repente hay algunos
problemas o que siempre van a haber
dificultades y por eso quiero darles 5
tips que le funcionaron a la jimena que
hicieron que se hizo el día de hoy y
hace que el título largo pero todavía
estamos hablando con el club para
cortarlo entonces el primer tipo que le
voy a dar fue es ya sea el bullying va a
pasar siempre y lo único que quiere
decirles es que hablen porque si éste no
habla las cosas no se van a solucionar
en su voz tienen un montón de
herramientas para hacerlo tienen
internet tiene a personas mayores que
puedan ayudarlos entonces hablen
lo segundo que quiere decir es que si
tiene algún amigo o conocido que tiene
un talento apoyen o sean por qué porque
realmente ustedes son la última
oportunidad que ese es talento salga a
la luz o manera en intento
porque porque realmente se puede
devolver a una persona mayor enojada
porque tiene un trabajo que no le gusta
y soltar los más jóvenes o quien sea
porque ellos están cumpliendo sus sueños
entonces apoyan lo tercero que les
quiere decir es que cada uno hace las
cosas a su tiempo si de repente si yo
tengo 23 años estoy publicando un libro
y tiene 40 y no lo están haciendo de
repente ya ya va a venir su tiempo pero
océanos no pueden de luchar por sus
sueños pero tampoco se preocupen dando
porque al final de siempre llega
entonces también
y ahí porque es porque hablo de esto sí
sí la charla se llama tu propia paleta
de colores porque estoy hablando de mi
vida aquí viene la cosa en este caso es
que
el libro habla sobre
sobre conocer tus colores solo sean los
colores de tu vida y que es serio
descubrir el 24 de mayo de 2014 yo
conocí los colores de vidas y cuales
fueron o sean los identifique con dios
mi familia mis amigos y que los buenos y
los malos momentos que hicieron a la
semana que es ahora entonces yo de
repente hace unos años yo no le podía
creer a una senadora que se diciendo con
ese pánico escénico con esa distracción
con sus problemas de no tener amigos que
está parada enfrente de ustedes
hablándoles como si nada no no me
creería entonces de verdad yo los animo
a que se tomen esa paleta y
y empiecen a aplicar su vida porque
[Música]
hay este colores como fríos que pueden
ser no sé la tristeza la seriedad de
repente colores más cálidos o pueden ser
los más felices entonces si le mezclan
siempre van a salir nuevos colores
entonces toman esa paleta y empiezan a
pintar su vida
[Aplausos]